Speaker 1: Former New Jersey Republican Governor
Chris Christie seems to believe that he could
beat failed former President Donald Trump in a
Republican primary. I'm trying to do my Tucker
Carlson laugh and I'm failing not maniacal enough.
This is funny for a number of different reasons.
Now I want to be really clear. Chris Christie is
a better candidate than Trump and Chris Christie.
The country would be way better off with
Chris Christie as president than Donald Trump
as president. But this is not what Republicans
at this point in time want. And Chris Christie
has no shot at winning the Republican nomination.
There's an interesting article in The Daily Beast.
Chris Christie believes he can take down Trump.
Does anyone else? Christie told The Daily Beast,
I think we'll lose if Trump's a nominee. That's
why I intend to be the nominee. This is very, very
interesting. I am the viable Trump alternative,
said Chris Christie to The Daily Beast,
swiveling and promptly ending the interview to
go to work the room at the Keene Country Club on
Friday night. That's in Keene, New Hampshire. So
you read the article and the framing is basically
that he is going to try to appeal to anti-Trump
Republicans without ostracizing Republicans who
do support Donald Trump. Okay. But as the article
points out, what is the math of this nonsense?
After polling no higher than 3% in any of the
surveys of the prospective 2024 field so far,
and after finishing in sixth place the last time
he went toe to toe with Trump, Christie seems to
be trying to answer the question himself before he
officially jumps into the race, which is how could
he be the nominee? His heart seems to want him to
run, but his head doesn't sound settle. Christie
seems to be leaning toward jumping in, posing and
answering questions that bolster his ability to
take down Trump, like whether he could actually be
a credible messenger to the MAGA base. Listen, I.
I want to have and one of the things about when we
have these discussions. Nikki Haley has no shot at
being the Republican nominee, but I've never once
said she shouldn't run. Anyone who wants to run
should run. It's absolutely anyone who wants to
run against Joe Biden should run. Everybody should
be running. Sure. But I'm also going to tell you
that Chris Christie has absolutely no shot. He
indeed is not polling ahead of 3% in any poll in
which he appears in some polls. He's either not
included because it's just all seen as very silly
or he's polling zero and just doesn't show up in
the poll for that reason. When he left office
in New Jersey, he had a 15% approval. So he's
not even really popular. Lowest of any governor
anywhere. He's not even really popular among New
Jersey constituents. New Jersey Republicans, I
mean, just it's just nonsense. And you have to,
of course, remember the completely pathetic
way in which he humiliated himself. Remember,
back in 2016, eventually Chris Christie dropped
out of the race, the Republican primary race, and
endorsed Donald Trump. And there was this I mean,
if the right loves to talk about alpha and beta,
it's not really the term. Those aren't the terms I
really use. But if you want to apply that filter,
there is it's hard to find a more beta event
than Chris Christie standing behind Donald
Trump after endorsing him and looking like he
had some bad clams on the Jersey boardwalk,
just nauseous looking. I'll remind you of that.
Speaker 3: One of the biggest things that
everybody is seeing happening and everybody is
the Republican Party has become more dynamic. It's
become more diverse. We're taking from the
Democrats would take it from the independents.
We have a lot more people. Any of the so many
places you go to different places and different
places in the Middle East, you look at some of the
airports they have. You look at the roadways. They
have you look at the transportation systems they
have and the trains they have. We're like a third
world country. You make some suggestions.
Speaker 2: Including some from a few of
your former aides, that some people inside the
Republican National Committee are considering
monkey wrench with your delegates state.
Speaker 4: Level.
Speaker 3: Trying to clear your way and maybe
even put. I think you know, David. Okay, good.
Speaker 1: All right. Anyway, so listen, Chris
Christie would be my choice if you said to me,
David, sir, the next president will be either
Trump or Chris Christie. I go with Chris
Christie over Trump a thousand times in a row.
New Jersey Republican former prosecutor has some
understanding for decorum and how to interact with
our allies on the international stage any day.
But that's me. It's me, a voter to the left of
Joe Biden who is going to choose Chris Christie.
There is no reason whatsoever to believe that the
Republican Party or any significant fraction of
it is interested in Christie over Trump. And
so I welcome anyone getting in who wants to
get in. Christie's campaign would be a dead on
arrival, and so is Nikki Haley's, by the way,
which we're going to talk about a little bit
later in the show. Make sure you subscribe
to the YouTube channel YouTube.com slash
The David Pakman Show. We'll be right back